good evening everybody before the
meeting starts I need to read the
emergency evacuation announcement should
you be required to evacuate the building
would you please leave the building via
the nearest available exit to the
chamber our assembly point will be in a
public car park at the side of the Civic
suite please don't - please do not delay
your evacuate evacuate to collect any
belongings please don't do not return to
the building until given permission to
do so by council staff and please note
that this meeting will be audio recorded
thank you
please be upstanding to receive the
Chairman the Chairman's chaplain and the
managing director good evening members
please please remain standing for
prayers evening ladies and gentlemen
shall we pray
loving and gracious God we recognize on
such events as this evening there are
periods of transition and change father
we give you thanks for this past year
where councillor David Merrick father
under his wise counsel and good
leadership we give you thanks Lord that
you have been presence in all of the
affairs that have taken place and Lord
as we come to that time of transition we
also pray for counselor Dre father Z
steps into this new role that Lord you
would strengthen father you would grant
him all wisdom father he would know a
sense of your peace and your presence as
well as your courage and strength and
for each and every one of us gathered
here tonight we pray that we would have
that sense of your presence likewise we
thank you for the privilege of serving
our communities and we pray that we
would always keep them in the forefront
of our minds and that we would hear and
discern your voice in leading us
gracious Lord we offer ourselves afresh
to your service and to the service of
our communities tonight thank you
please be seated
there you will all have received some
last-minute attender are you all happy
with those or do you want to stay the
meeting for five minutes to enable you
to have a look at them
anybody oh all happy to continue members
before I proceed to the main items on
the agenda I'd just like to say a few
words I would like to take this
opportunity to express my thanks and
appreciation to members for their
support and to many other people who
have supported me during the term my
term of office as chairman in particular
I will wish to thank the vice chairman
for his help and support notwithstanding
his work commitments and my chaplain
Reverend David ox Toby who has not only
given up his one free evening of the
week to attend council meetings but in
addition has been of immense help in all
aspects of the Holocaust memorial
service and civic service and has always
been there to provide spiritual advice
and guidance
I also wish to record my thanks and
appreciation of the sterling work of
Sonya Worthington who took on the role
of civic officer in addition to her
other duties when the previous Civic
Officer left and the dedication of Tania
Hill who became the sole civic driver
for some months until the vacancy was
filled not daring to be ill or to go on
holiday and finally I must thank my
principle group of
consorts counselor mrs. Carol Pavlin
mrs. Verna Carol and mrs. Pat Clements
who supported me so well during the many
Civic engagements which they kindly
attended with me
I'll now proceed with the first item on
the agenda which is to elect the
chairman of the Council for 2019 220
municipal Year council cap more it's not
the place over sorry chairman it gives
me the very greatest pleasure to
nominate account so Robin dray who's
been an excellent vice chairman in the
ural office to the office of chairman
for this year Thank You chairman
councilor step 2
Thank You chairman it's with pleasure
that I second that proposition thank you
we're all those in favor please show
anyone against abstentions that motion
is approved they will now proceed with
the
[Music]
congratulations Thank You Terry
[Applause]
I shall need now read out the stature
declaration I mr. Robin Richard ray
having been elected to the office of
chairman of the Council of the District
of Rochford declare that I tank that
office upon myself and will Julian
faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability I undertake to observe the code
as to the conduct which is expected of
members of Rochford District Council I
shall now signed the declaration of
acceptance of office
surely I would take but surely I'll take
item three on the agenda to elect you
sorry chairman
I think it's customary at this time to
actually speak of the Chairman the
former chairman now about districting to
say what a great year he's had
I think he's represented us extremely
well I know I've been at dues where
you've actually spoke on behalf of the
council got an excellent Civic dinner I
do hope you enjoyed yourself and seen
much of life not just in Oxford but all
around the county of Essex and other
places as well and I thank you for all
the work that you've done
thank you David I shall now present the
past Chairman's right to counsel America
right I shall now take item 3 on the
agenda and this is to elect the vice
chairman for the council for the 2019 20
new municipal year as a step toe
thank chairman a sweet pleasure that's I
nominate counselor Terry couple Thank
You counselor row Thank You chairman
I'll happily second that thank you thank
you
all in favor against this is counselor
cut more has been nominated as vice
chairman can you hear me now all those
in favor any against dad has been agreed
thank you thank you very much
Jesus thanks thank you thank you
don't you read that first this works yes
it does
what
I having been elected to the office of
vice chairman of the Council of the
District of Rochford declare that I take
that office upon myself and will Julian
faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment
ability nobility I undertake to observe
the code as to conduct which is expected
of members of Rochford District Council
Thank You members I look forward to
being here it's nice it's high up here
members I never take item five on your
agenda but the chairman of the council
to appoint a chaplain and it is with
great pleasure and delight that the
Reverend David ox Derby has kindly
agreed to serve as my chaplain for this
municipal year item six on your agenda
to receive apologies I've received
apologies from counts the meal and
countless Stanley are there any others
council hudson thank you any more no
thank you
item seven of the agenda the minutes
held minutes of the meeting held on the
30th of April 2019 are there green
members thank you item 8 on the agenda
announcements from the chairman and/or
head of paid service there are no
announcements from the head of pay
service but I'd like to take the this
opportunity members to thank you for
electing me as chairman and for the
trust imposed in me and I promise to
serve you all equally to the best of my
ability I'd also like to take this
opportunity of my giving my own thanks
to councillor David Merrick for the hard
work and diligence he has shown him
representing the people and communities
of the Rockford district and for his
support of me in my role as
vice-chairman
I had some 9 on the agenda to elect the
leader of the council for the 4th year
four year period or until the term of
office ends with effect from the 2019-20
municipal year
Thank You chairman chairman I would like
to get a nominate councillor Mike step
so for that office and I'm sure he'll
serve us extremely well
Thank You Chen councillor row Thank You
chairman I would like to second that
place thank you all in favour
any against that has been approved Thank
You members council accounts a step step
2
Thank You German firstly I'd like to
congratulate you on becoming chairman
but I'm sure that you're going to have a
very busy year thank you I would like to
I take this opportunity to thank members
for electing me as leader of the council
and for the trust they placed in placed
in you in my opinion brought to the
district council is one of the best
count councils in the country chairman
with your blessing I would like to take
this opportunity to say a few words and
propose a vote of thanks
the councilor Terry couple first of all
I'd like to congratulate him on his
becoming vice chair
terry was leader with his counsel for
some 15 years and I believe taking over
from Peter Webster those that remember
Peter I first met Terry when I was the
parish rep at the start of the original
standards committee was set which was
set up in the early 2000s and when I was
first elected to the council he gave me
the benefit of his experience and
encouragement Terry has seen a lot of
changes over the years such as the
change from committee to cabinet system
and working I believe with three
different chief executives Terry will be
a hard act to follow and I hope that I
will be able to call on his guidance
from time to time caused it I'm sure
that members will be happy to join me
and Thank You Terry and congratulating
him off on his role as vice chairman
[Applause]
my members with cancer Kappa would like
to respond chairman it's strange sitting
up here I know that we used to sit up
here we used to have some committees but
it's a long time since I've been up here
and still the sea of faces and all those
faces of people that came before us
which is quite daunting actually when
you're sitting here because you can see
them all we don't necessarily see them
from DaVinci's but it would be great to
actually try something different
as I say I've been member here for 20
years since 1999 15 years as leader so I
think it's about some way to be able to
change and I've got great confidence in
both my group and certainly their leader
and deputy leader they will take things
forward as they should be but I look
forward to the role coming forward and I
also look forward very much to working
with Robin as we go forward together
thank you my members are now shall take
item and ten on the agenda district and
parish council election results do
members note the district and perished
councillor election results as set out
in the report Thank You members item 11
on the agenda notice of group
memberships do members note the details
of the group memberships of the council
as set out in item 11 all agreed Thank
You members item 12 appointment of the
executive committees and subcommittees
2019-20
this will be presented by Angela law
Thank You chairman
item 12 is a report that sets out the
proposals for the discharge of business
during the 2019-20 municipal year the
council is invited to number one to note
the appointees of the executive
including associated portfolios number
two to constitute and agree the
allocation of seats to committees and a
subcommittee number three to appoint the
membership of committees and
subcommittee number four to appoint the
Chairman and vice chairman of committees
and subcommittees chairman taken the
first recommendation the deputy leader
and associated portfolios are set out in
addendum three to item 12 on page twenty
12.20 with a structure chart outlining
the details at each of the portfolio
holders on page twelve point twenty-one
and that is for the council to note
chairman to members note the leaders
appointees to the executive Thank You
members Thank You chairman also set out
in addendum three on pages 12 point 22
to 12.25 are the revised constitution
pages detailing the proposed changes as
noted to pages three point two six to
three point two nine or part 3 of the
Constitution for the council to approve
Chairman do members agree the proposed
changes to pages three points to six to
three point two 9 of the Constitution
relating to the executive appointments
is set out on pages 12 point 2 2 and
12.25 an addendum 3 which is which has
been tabled this evening all agreed
members thank you Thank You chairman
moving on to recommendation number 2 the
political composition of the council
should be reflected in the allocation of
seats on the council's committees and
subcommittees the revised appendix ones
to the reports set out at pages 12 point
10 to 12 point 12 shows the seats
allocations based on the current
composition in accordance with the pro
rata rules Council is asked to endorse
the revised appendix 1 chairman
he's a degree members Thank You chairman
revised appendix two to the report sets
out at page sets out at pages 12 point
13 to 12 point 14 details of changes are
required to the pages or in the
constitution of three point two one and
three point two to align with the
committees and subcommittees as set out
in the revised appendix one changes
required relate to the whole of page
twelve point thirteen and up to
including the chief officers appointment
committee on page twelve point fourteen
only counsel is asked to approve the
revised appendix two Chairman do members
agree thank you Thank You chairman
thirdly chairman group leaders have been
invited to nominate the council's
committees and a subcommittee item 12
addendum one commencing on page twelve
point fifteen running to page twelve
point eighteen sets out the membership
of committees and the subcommittee as
they would be taking on board the
nominations that had been received in
the office
these can be endorsed subject to dealing
with two nominations that have been
received for one seats on the planning
policy subcommittee from the Green and
Liberal Democrat groups can we please
chairman have a show of hands for
councillor Michael hoy
[Music]
and can there be a show of hands for
counts that Chris Stanley please
chairman
okay members please agree to endorse the
nomination set out in denden 1 on page
12 point 15 to 12 point 18 including the
appointment of counsel Michael hoy to
the planning policy subcommittee
is that agree members thank you
finally nominations have been received
on group leaders for chairman and vice
chairman of committees and for the
chairman of a subcommittee fees have
been set out in addendum to at page 12
point 9 a document that has been told
table this evening members and can be
and can be endorsed subject to dealing
to nominations that have been received
for the chairman of the review committee
chairman those nominations are
determined by a show of hands so for the
chair of the review committee can there
please be a show of hands for councillor
Burton
we all do
how many people are standing up Henry
counts as standing up all right there be
a recorded vote thanking members
councillor Burton
thank you
Yosi this is for councillor Burton yes
to be chairman of the review committee
thinking I think we have to be you can't
before council the person or gates
councillor Burton you got to be four
counts the person or for councillor boy
so I think perhaps the surname of the
councillor you want may be more
appropriate but I left town to the
person agrees okay
okay
yes okay when when given your voter
members then please give the surname of
the councillor you wish to be chairman
of the review committee thank you
okay councillor Burton surname please
cancel mrs. butcher Thank You counselor
canal
counselor mr. Carter
counselor mrs. Carter
canceler cut more councillor Dre
councillor Burton
councillor FD counselor Eve's counselor
mrs. Gooding councillor Hazelwood cancel
a hook way counselor
Missy toy counselor mr. hoi counselor
you are new counselor Lucas Gil
counselor mrs. Lumley counselor mrs.
Mason counselor mrs. Macpherson
counselor Marik
counselor Mountain counselor Newport
counselor mrs. Pavlin counselor mrs.
Rowe counselor mrs. Shaw cancel mr. Shaw
counselor Smith counselor sparing
canceler Steptoe councillor Ward cancel
a web counselor mrs. Weston counselor
Williams counselor Wilson counselor
Wharton thank you apologies counselor
working soon
[Music]
thank you remembers countless councillor
Burton has been elected as a chairman of
the review committee chairman for
clarification is 25 votes four counts of
Burton 11 votes for councillor hi
chairman can members please agreed the
appointments chairman and vice chairman
the committee's and chairman of a
subcommittee I set out on page twelve
point nine of the addendum to and
subject to the appointment of councillor
Burton as chairman of the review
committee is that agreement of its
members thank you
thank you chairman and that concludes
item of business thank you well now take
item 13 on the agenda the scheme of
delegation I ask members to agree the
scheme of delegation is set out in part
three a and C of the Constitution
subject to the amendments agreed in the
previous item and can I ask that
agreement a show of hands please members
all in favor
those against any abstentions that's
been agreed members thank you item 14
members agenda item 14 council meetings
I'm asking you to approve the scheduling
of the council meetings on the 16th of
july 2019 22nd of october 2019 17th of
December 2019
11th of February 2020 18th of February
2020 and the 21st of April 2020 is that
agreed members thank you item 15 members
appointment of Representatives to
outside bodies and other forums 2019 and
28 again
Angela law will present this item thank
you chairman members are invited to
appoint representatives to serve on the
outside bodies and other forums for the
2019 20 municipal year chairman taken
each recommendation in turn the council
is required to make decisions that set
out
pages 15.3 and 15-point for the report
recommendation one is for the
appointment of offices and put fair
holders to outside bodies for the
2019-20 municipal year on the basis set
out on page fifteen point five of
Appendix one to this report that is to
be agreed chairman subjects who note in
the nominee to attend meetings of the
south end University Hospital na NHS
Foundation Trust on behalf of a holder
for community detailed on page fifteen
point eleven of addendum to to the
report thank you these are agree members
thank you second is for the appointment
of member representatives including a
number of substitutes for the 2019-20
municipal Year to the outside bodies set
out on pages fifteen point six and
fifteen point seven of Appendix two to
this report the named bodies and the
nominations received to them are set out
in addendum one to the report on pages
fifteen point eight to fifteen point
nine that is to be agreed chairman
subject to dealing with two nominations
that have been received for the
substitute on the Essex flood
partnership board chair those
nominations are to be determined by a
show of hands so for the substitute on
the Essex flood partnership board can
there be can there please be a show of
hands for councillor I Arnie
and can there be a show of hands for
councillor Stanley chairman
so that is counsel I our new Chairman
Ken the appointment sets out and paper
on pages fifteen point eight to fifteen
point nine B agree subject to noting
counter IO new as substitute on the
Essex flood partnership board these are
the green members Thank You chairman
recommendation three relates to the
attendance by the leader of the council
and portfolio holders as the council's
representatives at a number of external
partnerships as detailed in paragraph
three point four the reports and this is
to be noted by the council chairman this
is noted members thank you very much
Thank You chairman recommendation for
relates to the appointment to three
seats on the sanctuary and Rochford
committee for the 2019-20 municipal year
the nominations are set out on page
fifteen point ten to be agreed by
council chairman is that agreed members
Thank You chairman recommendation five
relates to the appointment to the Essex
Police Fire and crime crime panel the
nominations are set out on page fifteen
point eleven or addendum two to the
report to be agreed by council chairman
is that agreed members thank you
Thank You chairman recommendation six
relates to the appointment to the Essex
County wide travel units the nominations
are set on page fifteen point eleven of
addendum two to the report to be agreed
by council chairman again agreed members
thank you
Thank You chairman and finally
recommendation seven relates the
nominations to the four seats on the
local highways panel and these are set
out on page 15 point 10 of the addendum
once a report to be agreed by the
council chairman said agree members
thank you
Thank You chairman and that concludes
that item of business that being a final
agenda item members I closed a meeting
at 8 o'clock
thank you very much members Barbella
scatter all to be upstanding for the
chairman leaving the chamber and
chairman it's the pleasure of the
Chairman to invite all those presents to
join him and the members lay out in the
members lounge for light refreshments
all were welcome thank you